so thanks for joining us this morning I
realize it's funny when you do when you
put together talk you look at your
slides on a little computer sometimes
things change when you put them up on
the big screen and I realized when you
put the words up your bus number on the
big screen it kind of sounds like some
kind of Scottish curse number that's not
what we mean and I'll explain that in a
second but first I'd like to go through
some logistics so this is a tutorial
this is not a talk this is not a talk
toriel this is intended to be an
interactive session and to help with
that interactivity Amy and I have
brought along a couple of colleagues so
Amy now by the way our research
mathematicians sometimes data scientists
are mostly an engineer from the
Institute up in Canada and we brought a
few along a couple of our colleagues
John and Leland also from the Tata
Institute to help TA this particular
session the idea is if you're having
trouble if you're falling behind if
something's not working we're gonna use
this old post-it trick and these fine
people are going to come help you now I
cannot think of a more overqualified
crew of TAS than these fine folks here
so if you do get more dove this
particular presentation if you're well
well ahead and you have any questions
about the fundamentals of data science
especially when it comes to say I don't
know clustering or dimension reduction
these are the people to pose those
fundamental research questions to
alright so here's how it's going to work
as we proceed through this through this
tutorial there will be times when you
have some audience participation to be
done I have two colors of post-its this
color here orange is for if you're
having trouble you're having difficulty
with anything at all just slap this
orange post-it on the back of your
laptop and one of our one of our
associates will come and help you out so
if something's not installing it's not
doing what it should which one of these
in the back of your laptop
conversely if everything is going smooth
actually too smoothly and you're so far
ahead that you're getting bored put one
of these on your laptop that will let us
know that we can proceed we don't have
to stall any longer and we can we can
move along with material ok so green
good please proceed Orange bad please go
we're going to pass these out everybody
please take one of each color
so bus number what am I talking about
when I say bus number in this particular
case a bus number is the number of
people they would have to get hit by a
bus before your data science project
becomes irreproducible
and for many people that number is
currently zero that is to say right now
your data science flow is not
reproducible by the way how many people
in this room right now the data science
where you can do is it fully
reproducible yes hands up no hands down
not a single hand excellent good to hear
by the end of this talk this tutorial
we're hoping we've given you a process
by which you can fully reproduce the
data science work that you're doing so
we're gonna take a couple of minutes now
to get started so if everybody could
please pull out your laptop and navigate
to this URL italy plus underscore number
underscore help and follow the
instructions there we're going to take
two minutes to try and get everything
started remember the post-its if you're
having trouble slap that orange post-it
on the back your laptop will be back
here in two minutes to bring it all back
on board okay just one one quick note a
couple of you have noticed one
particular problem already so is anybody
here experience an error with package
called NB dime okay a couple of you have
really easy fix in the bus number
director how many of you Benny for those
of you have got that far you've
obviously been able to to download the
new install from the cookie cutter in
that directory that was created is
called bus number and the very root of
that directory there's a file called
environment yml if you're having trouble
with this envied I'm saying what I want
you to do is I want you to open that
environment yml in a text editor like
say this one and there's two lines
you're gonna take out the two lines word
for which there is an error message and
B diamond env Val just take them out re
save that file and all should be good
any other question does that make sense
great I'm gonna add it to the wiki right
now okay how many people have been able
to get things installed how many people
are still waiting for somebody to come
visit them and help them
okay I have seen a number of working
installations which is wonderful I've
also seen a few not working
installations but I do want to proceed
with the tutorial so here's what we're
going to do if things are not working
for you at all I highly recommend you
turn out there to your left or to your
right and make a new friend we're gonna
pair a program does that sound
reasonable so therefore those of you who
do something working look around make
sure the person next to you looks like
they're doing okay if not introduce
yourself we're gonna work in pairs and
very quickly we're going to leave this
command line and move into the realm of
a Jupiter notebook and everybody's going
to get a lot more happy okay great or do
you want to open a notebook right now
okay ladies and gentlemen how many of
you are you here here because you want
by the time you leave this room your
process to be your data science process
to be fully reproducible most of you
that's pretty good for the rest of you
we ought to talk I want to talk to you a
bit about reproducible data science and
I want by the end of this tutorial two
things to happen one that everybody
leaves this room thinking that
reproducible data science is definitely
of a benefit to them and they want to do
it and two we want to leave you with the
ability to make your entire data science
workflow reproducible so for those of
you who did not raise your hand just now
I want to enter the mind of some of our
potential users my argument is this
everybody in this room can benefit
directly from reproducible data science
now I come from an engineering
background which means I do a lot of
building of things and testing of things
and so there's this trick that we use
when we're when we're building things to
try and get them right for our users
it's in UX design it's it's the idea of
a user persona so for those of you who
don't see themselves in this
reproducible data science environment
yet I want to enter the minds of some of
our potential users I want to introduce
you to a few characters who may be just
like you may have your types of problems
who are going to be a benefit from this
report
full data science this work here's the
character we're going to visit
throughout the rest of this tutorial
his name's burn yarns accom millionaire
he runs a test kitchen for IKEA you're
in Swedish but due to his proximity to
Finland he employs a large number of
finish line cooks who knows anything
about the Finnish language excellent
what do you know what the Finnish
language it's a very difficult language
why because it doesn't resemble any
other language really that we know of oh
maybe there's a Hungarian or Estonian
but that's it
it's a complete dead end linguistically
if you're a sweet got no chance of
understanding that that that's been next
to you unless you happen to speak like
like five languages like everybody else
in Sweden the Orang does not he wants to
build himself a machine learning model
to understand
Finnish this is his motivation but
Bjorn's a chef he doesn't want to have
to maintain this model what do chefs do
they hand things off to their sous chefs
to do that job yoren's happy to help
build this model in the first place but
when he's done he wants this to be
reproducible so he can give it to
somebody else to update later on recent
reproducible data science means you
don't have to maintain that model
forever you can hand it off to your
colleagues your colleagues are going to
love you your employer is going to love
you
your employer is going to have the kind
of consistency they need to continue
doing their jobs even if you move on to
a better job reproduce ablative science
is very good for people like the army
here's another character you might see
yourself in this is mark mark used to be
an astronaut he had a bit of a bad year
so he decided to leave the astronaut
business move to New York and start up
in fashion saying is marks a bit of a
science guy he's got to keep up with
tens of thousands of fashion submissions
all the time he wants to use science
through this job he wants to science the
field of data science he wants to
publish a paper about it but if he's
going to publish a paper and he needs to
convince his peers both in the fashion
and they need aid industry that he knows
what he's talking about his peer
have to be able to reproduce his work he
is not from this field he was an
astronaut to establish his credibility
other people need to be able to do what
he's doing his goal is to publish a
paper get his code accepted into
scikit-learn and changed the field of
fashion forever
why does beep reproducible data science
help here because if your peers can
reproduce it chances are other people
are going to use what you're it is that
you're doing
that stuff's going to be valuable not
only for you but the entire data science
community and finally Annie Annie writes
high-frequency trading software
she hasn't produced products per se but
she's constantly doing EDA she's
constantly looking at her data trying
out new ideas and then moving on to
another one you never know which one's
going to stick but she really needs to
get that edge here's the thing with so
many analyses going on all the time it's
very difficult for her to keep track of
what she did yesterday let alone what
she did six months ago
and when something jumps under that baby
you go oh wait I did an analysis but
what did I do how did I get that result
how did I get that edge she doesn't want
to lose all that work that she's done
she wants to be able to keep track of
the data that she's worked with of what
data she put into her models what those
models looked like after she trained
them and what the code she was that she
used to produce those results alright
and he's not doing this for a customer
and he's not doing this for her peers
she's doing it entirely for herself
reproducible data science means that six
months down the road
Annie will be able to redo that analysis
that she did that one time that one off
that EDA for her herself
okay so let's bring this all together
who are their potential customers for
reproducible data science well it could
just be you yourself it could be six
months later you who wants to be able to
remember what it was that you did here
at PI data it could be your colleagues
your colleagues are going to want to be
able to take that work from you when you
get promoted into that wonderful new job
or it could be your peers it could be
other people in the data science space
so regardless of whether you're doing
data science for yourself your
organization or the good of the world
there's a very strong case here for
reproducibility
so why is it data science reproducible
now it's got science in the name right
it should be reproducible science is
reproducible right
no laughs assuming that science is
reproducible there's a big problem when
it comes to doing data science what is
that here's a hint when we're doing data
science how much of our time do we
actually spend doing these science part
of it all of it 10% of it
closer to that what do we spend our time
doing munging data finding data cleaning
data dealing with problems in data we
spend our time here the problem right
now with reproducible data science is
all of that munching we tend to do off
on the side we tend to do by ourselves
and we tend to just assume once we've
got a useful product out of that that we
can just take that do the science on it
and that science is reproducible so
we're good the failure here is that
munging was not reproducible 80% of our
job is data munging and it's not
reproducible now that's I say 80%
because then we're doing supervised
learning it takes a while to train a
model supervised learning is not the
entire space it gets worse if you're
doing I'm the supervised learning quite
often you're just doing some kind of EDA
and a visualization how much actual
sciencing are you doing you're running
one algorithm out of scikit-learn 90%
95% of what you're doing is managing
data so in order to create a truly
reproducible data science effort we need
to focus on making every step of this
process whether it be obtaining the data
in the first place ensuring that it's
the same data I worked on six months ago
processing that data into something
useful and making that making sure that
we are allowed to use that data in the
place that we are actually deploying it
that's got to be reproducible the
science part sure we have to write good
code we have to document our code have
to store that code in a source code
repository I would argue we're largely
very good at that right now
I don't have to deliver that we have to
produce tables we have to produce images
we have to produce papers we'll haven't
talked about that when you produce a
figure for a paper or you produce a
figure for a slide six months later do
you know how you produce that figure
some yeses many many noes so
reproducible data science is about the
entire process so how do we do it so
today I'm gonna take you through one way
of doing reproducible data science this
is by no means the only way we've made
some decisions here for you based on the
way that we like to work so some of
these I think are great ideas and you
could take these home and run with them
if you want but what I want you to take
away is whether you use these exact
tools or something similar you want to
accomplish the same thing so what are
some of the right tools for the job of
producing reproducible data science well
the very first one is revision control
how many people here use get excellent
get is wonderful for source code it is
wonderful for maintaining revisions of
text documents how is good for
maintaining datasets hmm not so good why
lots of reasons data sets are big all
right they don't store well in a repo
data sets aren't typically text they're
usually bun binary tarball of stuff
right what change between this version
in that version who knows the whole
binary changed okay so storing data
directly in gate is not a great idea
storing instructions about what to do
with data and yet is a good idea now
when it comes to revision control is get
the whole picture
no yet is a wonderful tool like a hammer
is a wonderful tool but a tool is part
of something bigger how many people here
use something like github get lab or
bitbucket what these tools use these are
based around the idea of using git for
something but what they apply on top of
that is a workflow yet by itself has no
notion of a pull request anybody who's
ever dealt with source code and say
github knows what a pull request is it
doesn't that
workflow that you get from environments
like github gitlab bitbucket is
extremely important especially when
collaborating with your colleagues you
have to share a workflow so if you use
get today wonderful I highly encourage
you if you're not doing so I'm ready to
go the next step and use something like
github or gitlab to establish a workflow
on top of your gate use so revision
control super important we're gonna use
it today a language well we're at PI
data anybody here using Python all right
anybody here is in Julia mmm anybody
raising something else are I know
there's at least one in the crowd yeah
we go here y'all all right yes you've
got to pick your language of choice now
I haven't just said Python here I said
something else what'd I say
Python three point six why did I do that
why am I being a jerk in this residency
well why not just you know it's hard
enough to get people using Python 3 what
do you mean this Python 3 6 thing in my
experience so far incremental changes to
Python are great they add they add new
features which make my job a little bit
easier starting at Python 3 6 a couple
of changes came in that made my job
massively easier
what were those changes one of them is F
strings as if I heard this F strings in
Python 3.6 they changed they added a new
method of specifying stuff in a string
you know you want to put text in a
string we used to do it like originally
was just a string and then a percent
just weird and then you know a bunch of
a bunch of variable names inevitably
offset from where you wanted to put them
in the text that was terrible so they
came up with a better way it was dot
format and so now you had a string and
dot format and a list of variables is
stuck in there anybody who ever tried to
fit out on one line of code knows how
much of a nightmare that was enter a
strings so f strings are a huge boon to
making your code readable which to me is
a huge boon in making your code
reproducible the other thing that
happened in Python 3 six something
called ordered dictionaries extra days
are now ordered by default when you
iterate through the keys of a dictionary
they come back in the order that you put
things in it seems like a really tiny
change
but all of a sudden with that assumption
you can do things a lot easier than used
to do now technically that was a change
made in Python three six it wasn't
standardized until Python three seven
but it doesn't matter because as of
Python three six and onwards it's there
and you can rely on it so I would argue
if you haven't made the switch already
you should start using Python three six
or later to do your data science work
package managers and virtual environment
we spent a bit of time at the start of
this tutorial dealing with package
managers alright it is tricky at times
to get your package manager working now
I don't care whether use Conda or pip
and virtual environments or pip ends
that's not true I do care but you should
definitely use one of these and the
reason is is because as we saw at the
beginning of this tutorial it's
difficult to get your environment up and
running now we're just doing that for
one project this bus number project when
you start working on another project six
months down the road and some of the
packages have been updated and things
have been changing if you aren't using a
package management environment if you're
not using a virtual environment if you
managed to get that new environment
working the one here from the bus number
seminar is going to break it's just the
way of the world so you want to make
sure to use some kind of package manager
so that every time you do a project you
can write down you can record what those
dependencies you had and return to that
state when it comes time to do this
again does that make sense
so we've chosen condom why the beauty
day of science and condom makes it
really easy they build lots of stuff for
us they get they can handle dependencies
that aren't just Python great
you may choose something else pip end is
actually a great choice for this as well
and for reasons in fact pip benzos
something I'll get to a little bit later
that Conda does not and they do it well
frameworks
does anybody here you scikit-learn
alright everybody here should you suck
you learn if you program if you do data
science and python learn scikit-learn
the one thing they do let's ignore the
fact that implement all these algorithms
for us what they do a really fantastic
job of is process how do i do data
science what does the data science
pipeline look like how do i chain
together operations in a reproducible
way scikit-learn gets eight
stuff right highly recommend you look at
it and how they do things and then
buried in scikit-learn is this really
cool little tool called job live now job
live has a lot of uses I actually only
use it for one thing and that is
persistence dumping my data science
objects to disk alright it's very good
at this job live is kind of like a
pickle in Python if you've ever used one
takes an object and writes it out in a
format on disk but it works really well
on large data objects like say and the
arrays which we tend to use now IDE you
need a development environment how many
people here use Jupiter notebooks how
many people here do not use Drupal
notebooks excellent you guys are gonna
love this
start using Jupiter notebooks they will
transform what you do why because data
science is not about sitting down
designing a project on a whiteboard and
then just implementing it it's about
iteration it's about interactive
processing of your data and Jupiter
notebooks make that incredibly easy to
do scripting well scripting we want to
be able to automate what it is we're
doing here now the reasons we'll get
into a little bit we use make and make
files to automate that why cuz I'm gonna
argue the data science is a flow is a
directed acyclic graph of procedures and
make as a tool for doing that and
finally we started out with a cookie
cutter why what's a cookie cutter
there's a way of templating a project if
I want to start a new project today I
don't want to start from scratch I don't
want to try and remember what my
development environment looks like I
don't want to try and remember how to
set up the config files for all the
parts of my flow what I can do with
cookie cutter is I can set up a template
that I define once and then every time I
start a new project it uses that
template and customizes it for what I'm
doing hopefully most of you got
successfully used the cookie cutter this
morning to create the environment for
this alright highly recommend if you
haven't looked at them before that you
start looking at cookie cutters and
perhaps for your own environment develop
a template for your own use so these are
the tools we're going to use today as I
said at the beginning you don't have to
use these exact tools but I would argue
that you have to use something in each
one of these categories if you want your
process to be reproducible alright this
is not a tutorial I said that at the
start so let's everybody fire up a duper
notebook so for those of you who are
successfully able to create your
bus number environment I want you to
change into that environment source
activate bus number and I want you to
fire up a Jupiter notebook type Jupiter
notebook at the command line and we'll
get started hands up or green post-its
if you've been able to get Jupiter
notebook fired up those of you who have
not please buddy up with somebody who
has this is the fun part
so you'll notice when you fire up your
notebooks you will likely see a
directory list one of those directories
is called notebooks where do you think
you should look for our tutorial
notebooks directory called notebooks
excellent choice and in there you're
going to see something looks like this
reproducibility is all about standards
it's all about processes you can name
your jupiter notebooks whatever it is
that you want but six months down the
road when you're talking to yourself and
you're saying what did i do on that
particular project it's really nice to
have conventions about things like
notebook names where do you think we
should start first for this particular
data science project well I do have a
notebook called start here and that's a
good hint but it also starts with a 10
which just happens to sort to the top of
the list this is a really good idea in
fact when we're doing reproducible data
science we actually go a little bit
further with this now we tend to do the
number which is roughly speaking in
which order I should do this EDA comes
first it's maybe in the tens and then
science in comes second that's maybe in
the 20s or 30s and then publishing comes
third and that's maybe in the 40s or 50s
and because we typically have multiple
developers we usually put our initials
after that why because I may be working
on notebook 11 and Amy's working on
notebook 11 and we haven't talked yet
but that's okay because they have
different names and they have initials
so I know who to speak to and then
finally a little indication of what the
notebook is about it seems like a stupid
little detail but six months later you
is gonna thank me for making you do
something like this so start with the
start here notebook please
so here's a star here notebook this is
basically exposition a lot of the stuff
we talked about already installing from
cookie cutter if you weren't able to
successfully navigate the cookie cutter
I'm gonna show you here what it would
have looked like all right when you fire
up a cookie cutter here's the command
right here you don't actually have to
download that code you can just point it
directly at github and so what we've
done here is we've just told cookie
cookie cutter to install this thing
called easy data and check out a branch
called PI data New York City that's it
so that means that I can go and update
this cookie cutter in the backend and
you people can get all my updates
wonderful except shell if you update
that you're gonna break what it is I
worked on yes another important aspect
of reproducibility is if you do
something significant like say give a
tutorial at PI data create yourself a
tag tag your source code on that
particular day so that when you come
back to it six months later you can get
back to exactly the same spot in your
source code you may have changed things
but and I may change things in this repo
tomorrow but it won't matter to any of
you because I'm not gonna be working on
this PI data in New York City branch
tags are a really important way to do
that so starting the cookie cutter you
had to specify a project name that's
going to be the name of the directory
that was created we called it bus number
almost everything else in here you can
just hit enter at and really really
should this easy data cookie cutter
started as a fork of something called
cookie cutter data science cookie cutter
days science made a number of decisions
they wanted to support as much stuff out
of the box as they could and so they
have supported a number of open-source
licenses and a number of virtual
environment managers and a number of
versions of Python I don't want you to
use other versions of Python I really
want you to use Python 3 6 or newer
don't don't choose to I don't want you
to use virtual ends there is very good
reasons to use either conda or even
better pip ends an open-source license
while you can do ever you want there if
you want to share your code please use
one of these open-source licenses don't
make up your own license ever why how
many lawyers are here in the room don't
make up your own license ever that's a
job for a lawyer and people like at MIT
or the Berkeley software distribution
folks have done very good work too
Sulc with lawyers and make the minimal
possible piece of legalese you should
use that don't modify and except to put
your name in it if you want it to be
proprietary go ahead make it a fighter
that's kind of a default but at least
tell me that all rights reserved
something in your source code so we
specify the the the name of the the repo
I give my name because it's going to
customize a few files for me a
description because it's going to
customize a few files for me and take
the defaults for everything else lo and
behold it creates this environment and
now for those of you got it working you
that changed into that environment and
use this make command to automate a
couple things to create your Condit
environment in the first place you then
activated it then you did a second make
requirements why is that I'll get to
that in a minute there's some really
cool magic there and then you initialize
the git repository right there why
because you want to know what changes
you're making or during this tutorial
all the bugs that you're fixing you want
to be able to look back to say what it
was like before what changes did I make
and so you're gonna initialize the git
repo and then you're ready to go okay
data size process we talked about what
does a size look like munch munch munch
oh been science and finally data science
is a deck what's a deck directed acyclic
graph
what do the important features of an
acyclic graph especially when you
consider that as a workflow
what does acyclic mean no cycles what
would it look like if I started a
workflow with a cycle in it it seems
like I would never get out of it alright
data science is not one of those things
it feels like that at times but no at
some point it stops and so data science
is a series of steps which eventually
stop and what the step that I do now say
I want to work on my data I want to run
it through an algorithm may have
depended on steps before it but the
point is is that I might have to
indicate oh yes before I do this I have
to download and install my data but that
process is eventually going to stop and
there are tools to automate these types
of things and one of the oldest tools
for automating processes that were in
fact a an acyclic graph with
dependencies is something called make
and we're going to use make files and
make in the simplest possible way and
that is to define steps of a process and
all it is for us
is a way to associate a bunch of actions
to one command and that one command is
going to be make something something
being this step in the process that
we're going that we're going to do next
okay now you don't have to use a make
file to do this I recommend you use
something like it but you don't have to
and in fact all the things we're going
to do from that make file we can
equivalently do in Python for the rest
of this tutorial we're going to show you
how to do that but here it is here is
what I'm gonna argue is a reproducible
data science process start to finish and
what does it look like the first two
steps make raw and make data this is the
munging step what's raw raw data is when
I fetch something from the internet
alright I make it I get it from
someplace and then I check the versions
on it to make sure I know which version
it is make data I turn that data now
into something that I can use is raw
data every usable if it was we wouldn't
spend eighty percent of our time
munching it now would we
raw data is really useful so we have to
go through some kind of process of
transforming that those first two
bubbles there represent the munch
process next we actually move into
science we've made maybe we're doing
supervised learning and we're training
some kind of model on our data don't be
the make Train step and once we've got a
trained model we use it to do something
typically if we're classifying say we're
going to make predictions on a data set
right that's another step of the process
so that's where the science tends to go
and once we've done that science and
produce something out it beat a set of
predictions or a transform data set or
whatever it happens to be then we mark
it move into the last step which is the
publisher sharing and publishing I want
to analyze that data I want to take the
transform data I want to summarize it in
some way that might be creating a table
of data that I can put in a paper that
might be creating a visualization that I
can put on a slide that might be just
deploying in a notebook with some kind
of interactive bouquet demo right but
the point is we're going to reduce our
data set to something useful that's the
analysis and finally we're going to
share it with other people the purpose
of this picture is is several fold this
is a quick reference to the entire
reproducible data science flow it's also
a quick reference to where stuff is in
this flow physically on your disk at the
beginning step it starts on the internet
and ends up in directory is called data
slash raw data slash intro and so on
next step you take that stuff and run
into him and you turn it into processed
data saved in some place called data
processed and so on we're gonna walk
this through this in more detail but I
just wanted to know this is the quick
reference as to what it is we're going
to be doing ah it's a cheat sheet of
sorts which is why in that bus number
repo the you that you've just now
created I've given you a copy of this
cheat sheet where is it then directory
called references in a file called cheat
sheet so should you need this please
feel free to refer to it at any time by
the way where's the repo you I put it up
on a slide beginning now you've all
forgotten how do we get back to that
repo for this for this particular talk
anybody know yours hint behind me corner
of every slide there's a bitly link that
will take you to the bus number repo at
any point you get lost or can't find
something go to this URL okay everything
you need will be there
let's talk about raw data actually how
we doing how much time we got so far
1946 everybody want to put your laptop
aside for a second just like stand up
and stretch power a half's a long time
to be sitting here doing data science I
stand up stretch say hello to your
neighbor 30 seconds see you back then
[Applause]
I have a big house okay but are you
gonna be here on date as this question
was just asked so
ok ladies and gentlemen I'm gonna get
your attention back so just as we cut to
break there there was a question I have
a very good question so I wanted to
repeat it for everybody and I just
happens to be a question that was
answered in that very first notebook the
question was this what's make doing that
a shell script isn't OK why can't I just
write a single shell script to do all
this for me and the answer is makes a
little bit more clever than that it
basically make can bish be a series of
shell scripts but what it's doing is its
establishing this graph structure on it
some kind of notion of dependency so if
you're ever wondering what make does Amy
can you execute that cell if you're
wondering what a make command when I say
make raw or anything else and you're
wondering what it's doing under the hood
just do make dash n what that's gonna do
is that's going to display the commands
that it would normally run ok so here
it's just saying oh it would run a
Python script that says make environment
woops it would it would run this Python
script and then do this Conda command so
if you're ever wondering what makes
about to do you can just type make dash
in and run it yourself all right
and by the way I should mention this we
use a really clever trick that I totally
stole from cookie cutter easy data to
make our make files self documenting so
if you just type make it will tell you
all the targets that are available to
you based on the comments that are in
that make file this is a really cool
trick you should always use it so we
have a number of targets the targets is
just a name that you put after that may
command a mate can you keep going
aha so what does a make file look like
under the hood this thing you see here
thing to build colon and a space
separately list of dependencies this is
the magic and this is the answer to your
question what a make file is doing is if
I tell it to make that thing to build
its gonna know that before I can do that
I have to do everything in that space
separated list that's base separated
list is names of other targets names of
other things in my make file so if order
to train my model make train I have to
first build the raw data I can just put
train colon data in there and it will
automatically if it needs to run that
data processed first so it's a really
quick way so you asked about with how
this is better than a script put the
script as the thing that you need to run
there but then if there's anything
you've got to run before you can specify
it on that target line and this is just
a way of chaining together these various
scripts in a way that the flow is
automatic
all right here's an example Amy if you
could run that one for me here's an
example make file data : raw what does
that mean that means data depends on
having the process for raw run first
train test split has no dependencies
train depends on Ada and transform data
and train tests split transform data has
no dependencies in raw has no
dependencies okay
wrote that make file Amy can you run
that next up okay if I run this and I
say make train it's gonna follow that
train of dependencies in whatever order
specified there this is what happens
first it fetches the raw data then it
builds the datasets then it does a data
transformation then it does a train test
foot then it trains the models I didn't
tell it to do things in that order it
figured that out from the make file so
the really powerful thing here about a
make files lets you chain together those
little scripts that you write in a
sensible way I used the phrase directed
acyclic graph because make hates cycles
why cuz it would never finish if there
was a cycle so let's write that one out
if I write a make file that literally
links three things together in a circle
what does make a do it it's clever
enough to notice wait a minute I've been
here before I'm never getting out of
this loop and it's just going to abort
so if you make a mistake in your process
with a make file it'll help you out if
you make a mistake in your process with
us with our script and your write an
interval loop you'll be there a long
time until you realize what you've done
so these are two very good reasons to be
using a make file for this process so
hopefully that answers your question
all right let's get back to some raw
data the first part of any data science
process is acquiring the raw data to do
it and if there's one thing that you
take away from this obsession today if
you want your process to be reproducible
you've got to treat raw data sacrosanct
you cannot modify it why six months
later you will be very angry how many
people in this room if you did an
analysis six months ago how many people
in this room could tell me if the
upstream data sources changed what if
that CSV file that you depend on was
modified upstream will you notice that
don't modify your raw data what should
you do with your raw data instead check
hash it check what your odd it looks
like record the hashes record which
particular raw data files you used so
that you can use that information later
so the whole point of this collect raw
data process is simply to go to the
internet or wherever you're getting your
data from fetch things unpack them
because they're inevitably in some new
compression format that you just found
out about yesterday
and check verify the hashes that you
have saved since last time so that you
know if something upstream has changed
and I would argue that if you
successfully do analysis if you do this
thing once you should maybe save a copy
of these raw data files somewhere so
that when you come back and realize that
Yelp has changed the data set yet again
you still got an older copy of that Yelp
data alright and you can proceed now
where you gonna store that copy it's not
gonna be an get with raw data files I
highly recommend you go and try out
something like use an s3 bucket use an
Amazon use an azure bucket whatever it
happens to be use some kind of large
data storage place to drop these files
and you could do that because all you're
doing is dropping RAW files a compressed
tar ball a compressed zip file from the
internet somewhere on a disk and
rewriting down with the hash of that
particular file is in fact if you look
in that make file that you've got as
part of this bus number project there's
two lines in there about talking to s3
sync to s3 and sync from s3 and what it
does is it takes all the stuff all the
raw data that you've downloaded and
shoves it up into a bucket with your s3
credentials okay I didn't do that for
this particular tutorial I didn't use it
but you can recommend you go have a look
at that and use something similar in
your data process
so this is the data process let's take
data off the internet let's save it in a
directory called data raw and then
unpack it to an interim directory that's
the entire raw data process the next
step then is actually doing something
with that so the this is where most of
your time in the munch process is going
to be spent starting with that raw data
which you've not touched because it's
read-only singing with me I don't know
the two men either story is now we're
gonna process it in something useful so
now we're gonna do all the hard part
about cleaning extracting features and
doing a train test split and more
importantly than just doing those
processes we're going to write down the
sort of the metadata that goes with it
so for the next part of this tutorial
we're gonna do this process we're going
to start munching somebody's data in
this case I think we're gonna start
munching Beorn's data yes we are
so I've everybody could please fire up
notebook number 20 so let's do some data
science they don't remember Bjorn he's
the chef he's Swedish he doesn't speak a
word of Finnish everybody this kitchen
does he thinks they're talking about him
he wants to solve that problem with data
science so he's gonna build a model he
searched the internet and found a
wonderful project with some Finnish
phoneme data on it he's going to use
that to train a classifier and he's
gonna try a number of techniques to do
that classification and then compare
them at the end of the day ok so now we
could start shift entering through this
notebook which is what Amy's gonna do
for you so first what we're gonna do and
just set a dataset name give it a clever
name hardest problem in computer science
is naming things
so this dataset I downloaded from a
project called lb kupack I'm gonna name
lbq pack it doesn't matter what I call
it what matters is that I keep using
that name throughout this notebook how
do I do that
computer science gives me something for
that it's a variable I'll set my dataset
name to bat and just refer to that data
set name everywhere so if I change my
mind later and think that was a stupid
name I should have called it your data
or something I can change it in one
place okay let's keep going ah
so we're gonna save this someplace I
told you my recommendation would
be saving in a path called data slash
raw and then unpack stuff to data slash
interim problem you're probably working
on well right now you're working on your
laptop so everybody's got lots of space
in the laptops right yeah sometime
during this talk the warning is gonna
pop up in mind that says your disk is
full okay just so you know if this
happens to you you might know that when
you're working with data often you refer
someplace else than where you usually
are if I work on a shared computer at
work for instance usually the home
directors are locked down so I can't do
much in my home directory I always start
my development my home directory I
forget this but when it comes time to
put the data file somewhere they've got
places where I should put those data
files other file systems on other
computers so the point is is even though
I recommend you should use data slash
raw as a place to store it you may
change your mind you may want to store
it someplace else
don't hard-code paths in your code what
we've done in this particular project is
we've imported a source file source dot
paths it's just a very simple Python
file and all it does is it puts those
paths in exactly one place so anytime I
want to know where my raw data is stored
I just from source paths import raw data
path and now I can use that everywhere
in my code that means if I change my
mind partway through start moving to
someplace that has a lot more disk space
or is a lot faster disk I can change it
in that one place and everything will
work I don't have to hunt through every
line of code to find my data path so we
do that for just about everything how
many people in here if your program and
python use something called path Lib oh
yeah you guys should all start using
path Lib anybody ever type some like
this import OS OS dot path dot append
here's my old path here's my new path oh
wait I got to strip off the OS path
what's the strip off thing okay do that
first and then add it to this other
anybody ever done this kind of path name
munging okay that sucks if you don't
want to do that and you have to do that
there's this wonderful library called
path Lib that lets us do crazy stuff
like this raw data path slash as in like
the divide thing the rest of my path and
it just magically puts those things
together okay or raw data path dot name
raw data path dot parent or any such
like that they're really really useful
library and the really cool part is it
works regardless of whether you're using
a Windows box a Mac a Linux box it
handles all the platform specific stuff
of a munging path
it also looks pretty in your code and is
highly readable and readable means
reproducible right
yes readable means reproducible so
everybody start using path Lib
your code will be prettier you'll like
it a lot more so i'm source dot
utilities we're going to import
something called lister this is just a
silly little function that lists a
directory but because we aren't
hard-coding past anymore my path is in a
variable so if i want to see what's in
it
i don't want to switch to a command line
or anything I'll just run Lister on it
so what's happened well I got some files
there you probably don't have these yet
let's keep going
download and check hashes the first
thing we're going to build is something
that we call the raw data set a raw data
set is a collection of files and
instructions about how to get them the
best part is is that a raw data set can
be written out to a text file so you can
check it into a source code repo so
we're going to build a raw data set that
goes to the internet and fetches the
files that we need in this case for
bjørn's data set there's exactly one
place we have to go here's the URL so to
build a raw data set that that knows
about this create a new data set ldq
pack equals raw data set isn't that data
set name I gave it before and add a URL
to this raw data set so our data sets
now ready to go to the Internet to get
it it hasn't done so yet but it's ready
are we done
that all I have to do not exactly now
here's something we do very poorly in
data science I can download that data
from the Internet but can I use it maybe
it's on the internet I must be able to
use it right what if I'm shipping a
commercial product can I use it then
wait can I use it in my company at all
these are all really important questions
so I'd argue the first thing you do
after you obtain files or find them on
the internet is fill in two pieces of
information into this raw data set
first what is this thing that I've just
downloaded I call that desk er
description right I should record what
it is where I got it from and what's in
it just for a human being not for a
computer for me six months later me to
remind me what this with this data sets
all about and the second thing we should
do is find out if we're allowed to use
it let's obtain the license for this
file if they're a good data citizen
they've shipped the license with their
data if they're not you might have to
shuffle around read around on the
website to see if you can use it so we
have a few options for adding this
information to our raw data set we
always want to keep the data and the
instructions on how to use it together
for six month later you and so one of
the ways we can do that is we could just
if we can find a license file in here
now we could just add that as another
data file we can just download that
license file or tag it as the license
and Bob's your uncle so we can do that
because the readme for this particular
package that we're downloading is on the
internet that's cool
so what do I want to do I want to add
this extra URL just a text file called
readme that's a terrible name by the way
I don't want to save a text file on my
computer called readme why well cuz
everybody has a file called readme I
want to change that to something new so
I'm going to give it a new file name
data set name dot readme much clearer
and then I'm gonna say this is the
description of my raw data set a name
equals usually that's just a text string
but if you said name equals desc your
name equals license both uppercase
that's going to tag that as a special
piece of metadata one of those two
things okay so these were semi-good
citizens they had to read me telling you
what this this file was all about they
didn't have a license file in that read
on their web site they did have one in
the repo though so after reading
documentation of while I came across
this thing I want to put this in my raw
data set I want to store this
information about this license so six
months later I can I can tell if our
highly successful phoneme classifier can
be used as a commercial product so
here's the license text scroll down I'm
just going to specify it as a string
what do I know
oh this program is copyrighted in the
sense that it may be used for scientific
purposes the package as a whole or part
Sarab cannot be included in any
commercial application without written
permission so why did we do this
exercise we did this exercise to verify
that we are legitimately using this for
scientific purposes this is reproducible
data science it's right in the title but
we're not using it to ship a commercial
product we can't and six months down the
road when we come back and look at these
notes this raw data set will still be
tagged with the license that's why this
is the important second step after you
get a file add the metadata about what
it is and whether we're allowed to use
it and now I can just add that metadata
from that text string I created up there
and as a piece of license and that's it
I've got a raw data file I've got a
license file and I've got a description
text this is my raw data set so what am
I gonna do next
go get him go get a magic box fetch that
stuff I don't know what the I don't know
what the hashes of any of these files
are it's just something I found on the
internet so I don't tell anything with
that what does this do this goes and
fetches things Oh got to grab that off
the internet computer new hash for it
grab the other file off the net Peter
new hash it's going to save that
information in this raw data set so that
next time I do this when I load this raw
data set up off this it's gonna check
those hashes and tell me whether they've
changed you're not okay so Amy you can
run that cell again if you do this on
your computer hopefully by now you'll
have three new files anybody able to see
that all right you're successfully
fetched raw data from the internet
excellent
next step unpack the data this is not a
very interesting step run dot unpack on
it so if it happens to you download
something compressed like a tar file it
will then take that tar file and
decompress it to your interim data
directory and that interim diretor
directory is the unpacked version of all
the raw files okay by the way here to go
up just a bit Amy when I mentioned path
Lib and why it's so cool it's cuz I can
do stuff like this okay
interim data path slash data set name
that's a valid file name that is so much
more readable than OS pop append this
thing with something that's why I love
pepper okay so we've got a raw data set
object we created a raw data set what is
it just a color
should've files off the internet and
some metadata now we want to convert
this into something that we can use the
name of the object that we're going to
basically represent all our data with
from now on is a data set
pretty clever name huh naming things is
the most important thing hardest problem
in computer science so we're going to
build a data set object out of this raw
data what is the data set object for our
purposes the data set object is data
optionally target information if we're
doing supervised learning and metadata
about it that's it but by the time we
finish the process step that data
attribute of this object is going to be
the useful thing for us so our goal is
to transform the raw stuff we download
it into a data set object in a
reproducible way okay my raw data set I
can you call something called process
and what's it gonna do nothing how would
it have any clue what data this is right
now it wouldn't so process isn't gonna
do anything but it's gonna return a data
set object that has metadata because we
downloaded a description and and a
license file so that's cool we're
halfway there what do we not have oh I
should mention one of the cute things
about the data set object is if you've
got metadata you can just rather than
searching this metadata dictionary for
it you can just use uppercase attributes
so dataset dot uppercase license is the
metadata field called license data set
uppercase desc er is the metadata field
called desk here and so forth there we
go so the last thing we have to do to
make this data usable for our purposes
is to fill in this data and this target
field based on the data itself all right
let's do that
so if you look at your interim data
director you will find that things have
been unpacked directory called lbq pack
3-1 what's in their source code because
everybody ships their data as part of
stores code right why not that's it in
that kit in this particular case that's
what this is so we look through this
directory we see a bunch of C files but
more importantly we see a earlier ex1
dot and he
to death what are these ah we read the
readme associate with this it'll tell us
these are our data files so let's unpack
them let's create these wonderful path
Lib names for them make sure they both
exist on the disk yes they do this is
good and take a look at one of them this
is what the data file looks like what is
this this is process each data this is a
text file the space separated text file
that has phoneme made in it it's
actually been processed its phonemes
that have been recorded and then
processed down into a mail frequency sep
stream coefficient in the first twenty
of these coefficients have been written
down here and the label placed at the
end I don't really care about that but I
need to make this usable for my for my
data science purposes we have to be a
bit careful you can't just use a
standard like CSV or something import
for this particular file why because one
of the labels they use is this which
looks suspiciously like that which is
the comment in this file right so we do
have to write a custom piece of code to
process this this is not unusual you
download something off the internet I
guarantee 9 times out of 10 you're gonna
have to write some custom code to
process it in some way shape or form so
let's do that we're gonna write a
function here called read spaced l
emitted it's gonna read this file is
going to convert that space delimited
text file into in our case enum pirate
okay I'll leave that as an exercise the
reader to figure out what it's doing but
the point is is that when I call this
function on on my date of my test in my
my training data files it produces
something it produces a numpy and d
array of this particular shape here's my
data
it's 1960 two lines of twenty
dimensional data and my target vector is
also 1960 lines is good i got one target
for every pieces of data okay so I'm
successfully wrote a function to process
this raw data and give me something that
I can work with as a data science
scientist what do I do with it now I
have to attach that to my data set
somehow how do I attach it to my dataset
run that cell for me please any data set
up it has a very is a very simple object
it has in it name Davis that's always
have a name it has this data thing that
we've just computed it has this target
thing if it's a supervised data set and
it has some metadata associated with it
but I want to create a dataset object
all I've got to do is pass these options
to it if I want to write a custom
function to process something off the
internet and return a dataset object
what I want to do is I want to take
whatever logic I've just written and
package it up in a function that returns
a dictionary and that dictionary matches
this stuff here that means it's a
dictionary with these fields data set
name data target and metadata all right
so let's take the function that we just
created let's scroll down please and
we're going to wrap it up so what this
is almost exactly what I've done before
I've called this function process lvq
pack I've given it some options called
kind is one of the options that's
whether I want the training set or the
test set it's going to do exactly the
same stuff that I did before to get that
data in the target out but then when
it's done it's going to create a
dictionary and that dictionary is going
to have a data set name which is the
thing I pass in to it it's gonna have
that data vector that I just created
it's gonna have a target vector that I
just extracted from that data and
whatever metadata I wanted to store
about this okay it's just going to
return that dictionary writing a
function like this is all you need to do
to create a data set object so
processing function is something which
takes a data set name and any other
options that you want and produces a
dictionary and that dictionary can be
used to create a dataset object so if
you scroll down a bit you're in so Oh
Jupiter notebook trick if you want to
put this function someplace where the
code can see it I recommend you in this
particular case using a file could look
a dated that local data pie why because
our code just reads this file and
everything's in that in the name space I
want you to save it there in a duper
notebook if you put that magical thing
at the top this file what it's actually
going
right the contents of this cell to that
file so I'm just gonna write this file
to disk and this is gonna become a
source file in my repo they're not from
my notebook which is kind of fun so if
you do that if you run that cell if you
uncomment that file thing at the start
run it you'll see at the bottom
overwriting blah blah blah I've now
created this file it's now part of my
source code repo and now I can do this
from a source dot data local data import
process lvq pack that function here that
I just wrote alright and what can I do I
can call that function so it works I've
successfully built a function I've saved
it in a file in my source code repo and
I've used it to build these datasets
that's very cool
so let's add this processing function to
this data set and then we can call it
done so there's two ways to interact
with this particular workflow I
mentioned make files okay you can type
make raw you can type make data you can
make train the other way to interact
with these things is through a module or
a source style called workflow I've
tried to wrap any function which is
going to be useful to this process into
this workflow file ok so almost anything
you want to do to work with it it's
going to be workflow dot something so
raw data here's the documentation for it
I wrote you a doc string because I'm a
I'm a friendly programmer but the point
is is that to add this raw dataset to
our to our yeah there's a lot of doc
string I've heard a lot of doc string
alright keep up you can skip that I
really like you guys ok so that live
talk I'll be compact load function
equals process lb cube back that's thing
that I imported that's the magic here
right we've already added the raw files
we already added the license in the
description that's the part that adds is
the little piece of glue to process this
into something useful and now that I'm
done that lvq pack raw data set is
complete I want to add it to my personal
catalog of raw data sets workflow dot
add raw data set okay and so if I want
to use something from my catalog I can
now just say data set from raw and give
it that name and what's it going to do
it's going to do all this stuff is
go to the internet fetch those files
check that the that the the hashes that
I have are valid apply the processing
function at the end of the day return me
a dataset with data filled in target
filled in and all the metadata filled in
this is a fully process to data set at
this point this is an object which you
can use to do data science okay let's go
one of the things that we do in this
workflow of module is we create sort of
a catalog of things for you to use we
give them names
so raw data sets have names datasets
have names transformer functions have
name scoring functions have names and
whenever we want to join up two pieces
of the workflow we just create a text
file of some kind JSON file usually that
says connect this raw data set to this
transformation function so if I want to
turn a raw data set into a full-on data
set I had a very simple transformation
function which does nothing it's kind of
the identity function so add a
transformer starting from a raw data set
Amy if you run those yep and I get my
transform list and what I created
I've created a transformation function
that starts with a raw data set named
lvq pack and ends with a data set called
ldq pack and that's it so maybe could
you run this cell here make data make
data is going to do all that it's going
to write it's going to go to the
internet download the files or if you've
already got them locally it's going to
read those files check their hashes make
sure they're valid apply the processing
function to it and write out this data
set object on your system and so when
you're done you can simply do this data
set dot load with your data set name
okay so I load that up asks for metadata
only and show me that I've got a zombie
so anytime we want to six months down
the road access this data set what have
we got
I want to load it up lvq data set load a
database name this case it was called
lvq pack the object I get back is this
data set object okay in that data set
object ami connect a per second I'll
just show you what you got
this is a data set object it has
metadata associated with it
so lvq from file dot license oops
typing it's not my strong point that's
the license information we stored desc
er that's the description that we stored
data this is the thing we're going to
use as a data scientist target that's
the target array that we're going to
that we're going to use as a data
scientist basically everything that we
need to be able to do with this data is
now packaged up into this saved on disk
so I can load it anytime just by
reloading my Elvia cube pack data set so
what have we done
I'm going to step back a little bit here
we spent a lot most of our time in this
tutorial working on the very first part
of the process which is this idea of
munging data
when I showed you that workflow diagram
in the beginning make raw make data make
process what we've been doing is part of
this tutorials automating those various
steps so if I type workflow dot make raw
it's going to do all these steps of
fetching the raw stuff in the disk I'm
going to show you where we actually save
this because we're running a little bit
short on time now
so the first thing we do is go to the
internet and download some files we save
them in this data rod directory
the next thing we did was we
we unpacked them we unpack them to the
directory called lvq pack yep then we
process them into this data set file
this is the thing that we're going to
use to do data science from now on that
data set that's the on disk
serialization of this data set object if
I type data set load data and I give it
that particular name it will
automatically load this object for us in
fact under the hood what we were doing
is wiring up all the logic to fetch to
do these make file targets bet raw
unpack raw process raw and then make
data it is a kind of pickled file I use
a job Lib which does a much better job
of pickling numpy and D arrays but I
guess I don't think you keep pointing of
that I'll finish off a couple of quick
notes I just want to finish up here with
with a couple notes about what we've
done throughout this process we've been
importing stuff from a module called
source this is actually there's a really
really cute piece of glue that made all
that possible source is actually just a
directory on our disk that's where we
happen to be keeping all the source
files associated with with this project
the glue to actually make that work is
in this environment yamo file and it's
actually this line right here when I
make create environment the beginning or
make requirements at the beginning what
it did was it used pip to install an
editable version of the current
directory this line here looked in a
setup dot pi file and said hey this
directory here called source that's now
a Python module anything I put in there
can be treated like a Python module and
importantly imported like a python
module
so anything I've saved in this
particular directory here shows up as
importable in my source code so when I
develop a new piece of code like you saw
me doing the notebook here to process
that raw file if I save that into this
particular source path it just becomes
loadable as a module this is really
useful because not only does it doesn't
mean that you have a place to put your
code as you develop it it means at the
end of the day you've got something that
you can ship and share that is a pip
installable module so all the source
code that you packaged up is already pip
installable you can use it free notebook
you can share with your friends so I'm
gonna finish up here look back to the
slides it includes the instructions for
generate the data sets so here's what
we're gonna save all right here's what
we're here is what we're going to save
the instructions that we saved on disk
are all saved in the form of JSON files
so I don't have to save these raw data
sets because when I make data I don't I
don't load the raw data so from disk if
it I do if it's there but it was not
there I go to the internet I fetch the
raw files I apply this tiny little
function that I wrote to process those
into a data set and I produce that same
data set at the end of the day all right
and every time I do that I get I know I
get the same source files because I've
checked the hash on that and I get the
same output so I get the same data set
by load does that answer your question
yeah so everything that we save is in
the form of a text file and easy
description alright the day a science
process so we've processed this data
we've saved this this data set out the
next the next job will be training the
models so we don't have time to go
through the rest of this process but
this is the part where we start to get
good and as part of this is this bust
number data size process we've set up a
pipeline of operations you can do it
I've given you the notebooks that you
can now page through and look at this
reproducible data science process so the
next thing you do is typically train
these models you've got
and now you load it up and do data
science on it and you would save those
trained models into this directory here
a trained model for our purposes is
anything that looks like a scikit-learn
estimator that's really important that's
a really powerful thing because we use a
scikit-learn
estimator it doesn't have to be a single
function in scikit-learn and it can be a
whole pipeline of them but the point is
it's the same API to do a pipeline of
operations as it is do a single
operation so we train that model with
potentially a whole pipeline of things
and we save it on disk as a pickled
version of a trained psychic learn
estimator not sure the open models train
and then we transform our deal this was
a Finnish phoneme classification task so
the object was to take a look at the the
input data and produce a prediction
vector all right now prediction
information we saved in models output
and we achieve that by flowing our test
set through this trained model and
saving on disk in models output and
finally keep going there we go
we'd summarize so the final step we want
to do is take those models analyze them
and produce the summary data necessary
this is actually all automated in these
notebooks so let's look back I'll just
finish this up for now flip back to
these notebooks you've got this entire
process starting here we worked through
in gross or in gross the process of
adding and munging a data set training
and predicting as in there's no book 30
and the analysis part of it is in a
notebook 40 at the end of this process
the whole the thing is going to end up
being scriptable so that if I change
over to say a command-line documents
davell yet I can do stood a source
activate West I can do stuff
like this make raw fetch my raw data off
the internet make data process it make
train do the training make make predict
do the predictions and so forth
everything I do is going to be
producible everything I do is going to
be savable in a source code repo and six
months later me is going to love me
sorry guys we ran out of time to get
into some more Mead the presentation we
got a couple minutes for questions I you
can always corner me in the hallway
afterwards and as always you want to get
hold of us visit that repo give us your
comments and thanks for your attention
[Applause]